King Charles III is already making his
mark on Britain but here at the
goldsmiths company one of Europe's
oldest precious metal authenticators
it's more literal
hallmarking is a legal requirement for
the sale of precious metals in the UK
and it's a regulation that dates back
centuries but this year Goldsmith is
doing something a little bit different
continuing a tradition begun in 1934
with the Silver Jubilee of King George V
and Queen Mary goldsmiths are
authenticating gold and silver submitted
to them with a new coronation Hallmark
hallmarking is Britain's oldest
continuous form of consumer protection
and it goes all the way back to the year
1300 so this is the time that the First
hallmarking Act is passed and the idea
then is to make sure that on scrupulous
goldsmiths don't sell items pieces of
jewelry maybe you know Cutlery to the
public that has got too much base metal
mixed in because for most people if you
just look at an item it looks gold or it
looks silver but you can't really tell
quite how pure it is
2022 was an exceptionally busy year for
the London assay office with the late
Queen's Platinum Jubilee but this year
is turning out to be just as busy tens
of thousands of pieces of gold and
silver hallmarked with the king's
moniker have already passed through
these doors and if you've ever wondered
where the term Hallmark comes from it's
from this very Hall pieces have been
authenticated here since the 1300s it's
an institution almost as old as the
monarchy itself
the process used to involve the new
stamp of approval had to be sanctioned
by the British hallmarking Council and
can be applied by Punch or laser the
coronation Hallmark is available to
Jewelers silversmiths and retailers up
until the end of next year
when you're applying the mark you want
this line touching your thumb that's the
one that faces towards you
methods of hallmarking have modernized
with time with much of the stamping now
Happening by laser engraving however the
old ways are still being used thousands
of times a day sometimes we have to
place it back in again to make sure it's
uh at the right depth all the way around
getting all the detail out so that it's
a pristine Hallmark at the end for the
consumer to look at it can verify that
it's silver but obviously this is the
coronation Mark to indicate it was
Hallmark this year even though
goldsmiths has been around longer than
Buckingham Palace the Guild Hall and
even the bank of England practices have
changed since the company's Inception in
1327. we've invested heavily in x-ray
testing equipment and lasers for
hallmarking that allow us to process
items extremely quickly and minimizing
that disruption to the supply chain all
the Glitters isn't gold but this
coronation has all the Hallmarks of a
historic occasion